hey guys this is Vicki with Mac's tech
and as you can see I'm working from home
right now for the next two weeks at
least I've got my little helper Eugene
right over here so I want to take a
moment to thank you guys for watching
our videos hitting the like button
sharing it with other people so without
further ado let's get into this
comparison so as you guys can see we've
got the 20/20 iPad pro right here we've
got the 2018 model and in this video
we're going to be comparing basically
everything we can between these two
models performance speakers microphones
and a bunch of other tests so let's go
ahead and unbox this guy right here get
rid of this plastic look at this beauty
we've got the silver model right here
nice first I want to take some of this
out as you guys know we get our 18 watt
USB C charger with our USB C to us PC
charging cable right here so as far as I
know everything on the front is
literally identical I'm not seeing any
difference no difference in the bezels
the display reflectivity everything is
literally identical as far as the layout
of the buttons and the speakers
everything is identical here on top as
well no difference on the bottom with
the port or with the speaker grills so
one tiny difference is at the new twenty
twenty iPad pro weighs a little bit more
1.04 pounds compared to one point zero
three now that's probably due to some of
the internals I don't think that the
metal has changed at all I don't really
feel a difference maybe it has so
hopefully nobody experiences bending
issues with the 2020 model now the
biggest difference we see right here is
on the camera bump so we've got this big
square bump just like on the iPhone 11
Pro compared to this single little lens
like on the iPhone 10 R and as you guys
can see we have a brand new ultra wide
lens right here and a lidar scanner
which we're going to be testing both of
those things later on in the video now
because of this square bump apples smart
keyboard for the 2018 model will not fit
the 2020 so Apple came out with a brand
new one that has the square bump cut out
of it but we actually prefer the bridge
Pro keyboard that we have right here now
because it doesn't cover the back it has
these hinges so this technically will
work perfectly fine with the 2020
let's go ahead and try it out we're just
gonna grab this and slide it into these
rubber hinge holders and there you go
but the bigger deal is Apple's brand new
magic keyboard that's going to be coming
out in May it actually packs a trackpad
built-in and that actually makes the
iPad float which is really nice there's
also the bridge Pro Plus which also
comes with the trackpad that's going to
be coming out soon as well now both of
those track pads are going to be used
for Apple's brand new cursors support in
iPad OS 13.4 which actually supports
both the 2018 and the 2020 and a bunch
of other iPad models we've actually made
a full guide on that cursive support
that you can check out after this video
if you're interested in the new iPad pro
is actually exactly the same thickness
5.9 millimeters same as a 2018 model but
what's interesting is that the new iPad
pro actually has a slightly smaller
battery now I don't think that's going
to make much of a difference for battery
life because it does have a new a 12 z
chip which I think is more efficient so
you're gonna get the same battery life
we'll talk about that chip in just a
minute now let's go ahead and power this
new iPad pro on so it's pretty sweet is
on our 2018 model we got this little
pop-up allowing us to set up the iPad
using the Apple ID Apple didn't mention
any differences in the face ID speed so
we're gonna go ahead and set it up and
we're gonna see if it's faster alright
once again 20/20 right here 2018 right
over here let's go ahead turn them off
and we're gonna be trying out face ID
speed literally identical once again
literally no differences in face ID as
expected so as far as I know the
displays haven't changed one bit you've
got the same great LCD display laminated
very low reflectivity now as far as the
display brightness it should be the same
but just in case I'm gonna go ahead and
check out the maximum brightness
they're both maxed out right here we've
got the Google homepage and as far as I
can tell they look identical no
differences in brightness they look very
very bright 600 nits now of course both
of these iPad pros have Pro motion
technology which means the display
refreshes at up to 120 Hertz so
everything's going to be super smooth in
beyond the homescreen browsing the web
or using apps which support 120fps and
it also goes down dynamically to 24
Hertz if you're watching a video that
was shot at 24 fps so with that let's
get into our speaker comparison between
the 2020 and the 2018 model to see if
there are any differences or
improvements in the speakers
[Music]
[Music]
now let's move on to the camera
comparison now both of these still have
a 12 megapixel main camera so you guys
are looking at shots using the main
camera on both of these let me know if
there are any differences but of course
the 20/20 model gives the AUSA wide
camera so here are some shots using the
ultra wide let me know how they look I
personally think this is a great
addition even though not that many
people use their iPads to take photos I
personally love the ultra wide camera I
use it a lot on my iPhone so kudos to
Apple for adding that on the 20/20 model
now the selfie camera didn't change but
one difference I'm noticing between
these portrait photos is that my shirt
is not blurred out on the 20/20 model
which is pretty interesting now one
thing that's new on the 20/20 model is
the studio microphones Apple said the
microphone should be sounding better so
let's compare them this is a microphone
quality tests on the 2018 iPad pro this
is a microphone quality tests on the
20/20 iPad pro now before we get into
our performance comparison I want to
test out the brand new liner scanner
which is right there
this is gonna greatly help out depth
sensing which is very useful for
augmented reality so we're going to go
ahead and test out some of those apps
here's an app called the birdcage it has
an AR mode so let's go ahead and test
that out so I can place this birdcage
wherever I want so let's place it right
here as you guys can see you can adjust
the height and sports tracking seems to
be doing pretty well on the 2018 model
now moving over to the 20/20 iPad pro
I'm not noticing much of a difference
actually here's one difference as soon
as I move away from the table it
instantly knows that is going over
carpet and it matches the size perfectly
just like that right but here we are
back on the 2018 model and when you go
over carpet it actually starts glitching
out you see that it doesn't realize that
you're going over carpet so the depth
track
look at that it still doesn't really
know where it's at going back to the
20/20 look at that
instantly snaps into place and it
actually knows how far it is away and it
gets much smaller The Birdcage gets
smaller
yeah the depth sensing is definitely
better with the lidar on the 20/20 iPad
Pro now I don't know how big of a deal
this is going to be to a lot of people
especially right now we're gonna have to
wait on a lot more AR apps to come out
but for now there isn't really that big
of a demand for really good AR hardware
so with that let's jump right into our
performance comparison between these two
the 2018 iPad pro has the a 12 X chip
compared to the a 12 Z chip in the 20/20
iPad pro so Apple chose not to switch to
the a 13 X which means there probably
isn't that big of a difference in
performance but we'll test it out and
one more thing to know is that the 20/20
model has 6 gigabytes of RAM compared to
4 on the 2018 iPad pro unless you get
one terabyte of storage so we're gonna
start off our testing with Geekbench 5s
CPU test so we got our scores right here
and it looks like they're basically
identical this is within a margin of
errors for both a single core and the
multi-core scores so let's jump into the
metal test so in metal we're actually
seeing a slight improvement for the
20/20 iPad pro about 690 points so that
obviously isn't that big of a difference
so let's go ahead and run some other
benchmarks like antutu here are their
scores for antutu and as we can see we
have a little bit better performance
with the iPad pro looking at the CPU
scores they're basically identical the
GPU actually did go up just a little bit
and so did the memory so that's the 6
gigs compared to the 4 gigs
let's also test and two twos html5 test
to see if there's any browsing speed
differences and here are the results for
that basically identical in the html5
test now there's one last thing I want
to test for performance and that's video
editing export time with Adobe Rush so I
have an old 4k HEC 60fps project loaded
on both of these so let's export them
and see the time difference so as you
guys can
right here the 2018 iPad is actually a
little bit quicker for this export it
finished seven seconds quicker than the
20/20 iPad pro now this didn't really
make much sense considering that we were
seeing a little bit more performance on
the 20/20 model but realistically
there's basically no difference in
performance between the 2018 and the
20/20 iPad pro now one thing Apple did
mention is that they did improve the
thermal performance of the 20/20 model
so that's going to help for tasks like
long term video gaming sessions which we
actually are gonna try so make sure
you're subscribed if you aren't already
now one interesting feature you get with
a 20/20 model is Wi-Fi six support which
you don't get on the 2018 so let's go
ahead and test the internet download
speed now even though we don't have a
Wi-Fi 6 router we're gonna go ahead and
see if we get a more reliable connection
on the 20/20 model look at that sixty
eight point eight megabits per second on
the 20/20 iPad pro and for the upload
speed it's basically the same at six
point three nine to six point five seven
megabits per second so I ran the test
one more time to be sure and yet we're
getting over double the download speed
on the 20/20 iPad pro so if you're
worried about Wi-Fi speeds the 20/20
model is definitely the way to go
now before we get into our conclusion on
which one you should buy between these
two models I want to mention the prices
and the specs both of these retail for
$800 the only difference is that the
2018 model came with 64 gigabytes of
storage and this one comes with 128 gigs
and of course you get the other features
like Wi-Fi 6 the extra camera you get
the light our sensor better microphone
so that's actually a pretty good deal
the 2018 model is actually on sale right
now on Amazon for 674 dollars but I'd
say that's not that great of a deal if
it was maybe 600 I would recommend it
over the 20/20 model but remember that
you're getting double the storage with
this one for 800 dollars
brand new and the extra features so with
all that said let's get into our final
conclusion now we didn't see much of a
performance difference and that's
because the 2018 iPad pro was already
overkill for the apps that are available
on the App Store into
be honest the performance is still
overkill today so that's why we're not
saying that make of a jump because it
honestly didn't really need it but my
personal opinion on the 20/20 iPad pro
is that it's even more future-proof than
before that's because it has the extra
cameras it's got the lidar sensor for
better augmented reality for the future
when we start seeing better augmented
reality apps but overall what I would
say is that if you already have the 2018
iPad pro absolutely do not upgrade there
is not that many changes with the new
model but if you're choosing between
these two I would definitely recommend
going with the new 20/20 iPad pro for
the extra future proofing the extra
storage for the price is definitely a
better deal and a better choice
hopefully you guys enjoyed this
comparison if you did tap that like
button below and click the circle above
to subscribe and check out one of those
two videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]